hey welcome to the 360 live pre-show
Conan O'Brien here and this is cool you
are inside my personal office at Warner
Brothers this is where the magic happens
and by magic I mean this is where I sit
and I'm depressed and hate myself for a
huge period of time before the show let
me show you around it's pretty cool
we've got a nice office here here's my
door I have an old typewriter and I
typed Lincoln's Gettysburg Address on it
a couple years ago and put it up one of
the greatest speeches of all time and
then I pretended to sign it a Lincoln
people get impressed but it's not
Lincoln's signature it's mine I got some
cool mementos here some really nice
letters from people that have worked
with me look at this isn't this cool
this is something Andy Richter gave me
it's shows you the skeleton of the
Pillsbury Doughboy
isn't that cool he gave that to me like
five years ago and I absolutely love it
I've never looked at the Pillsbury
Doughboy the same way again
I've got some Jameson's here I don't
drink hard alcohol but I like having it
so I look like a sort of tough guy this
is my podium right here where I go over
monologue jokes or go over scripts
during the day these are various little
solutions that I spray on my glasses uh
this is my BlueCross BlueShield health
card oh here's something cool forget
that happened this is a button check
this out this is really cool this
automatically closes the door I love
this hey sonic can I talk to you for a
second
Sona it's my assistant Sona I don't
forget it gets me every time
here's a cool phone that I got when I
was in Armenia with Sona we did in
Armenia travel show and I bought this
phone when I was there and it's got
Russian lettering on it because of
course Russia controlled Armenia back
then
here are some boots I got on my neck
socotra 'p from former President Vicente
Fox no effing Wahl referring of course
to Trump's proposed border wall and
these are cool boots I've got a bust of
John F Kennedy there another Irishman
from Brookline Massachusetts
I love my American presidents there's
harry s truman personally signed by
harry s truman there's my California
Republic flag right here
this is where we write down who's gonna
be on the show this week and what
comedies planned as you can see we're
having a little bit of a rough patch
right now just kidding this is a dark
week so that's why that's clear a fan
made this you may have seen this before
I made it completely out of scrap metal
it's a little Conan one of the most
creative things I ever seen Andrew Smith
made this shout out to Andrew Smith
that's absolutely beautiful and actually
what my real skeleton looks like I've
got this is cool this is uh the pins
from last year's comic-con someone put
these in plastic and gave them to me and
so I keep those this is a map of the
United States and then of course a map
of the world most evil people like
myself love a map of the world Stalin
had one and just pretty much anyone who
wants to take over the world has maps of
the world that's me and I want to spread
my form of comedy throughout the region
takes us back to this area right here
this is a quick check look at this this
is a lot of Pedialyte a couple days ago
I was vomiting violently because of a
stomach bug and I had them go get me
Pedialyte I said so now get me some
Pedialyte she bought me like nine giant
bottles of Pedialyte I had to get
through the show it wasn't easy but I
got through the show it didn't vomit
once but I had a bucket under the desk
in case I had to that's the kind of
dedication I have and I love this right
here I also got this in our media it's
an old Russian like way of telling what
day and date it is I love I just love
stuff like this you know simple low-tech
this was the original Apple watch when
they first came out with it is what it
looked like and oh I think them at a
time someone's trying to get in here
pretty much that's my office I hope you
enjoyed it 360 techno you owe
- pod I don't know peace out